le trail c'est souvent le type de course
dont on se souvient pour les pentes
gravisées à la foulée et la course de
Magny-les-Hameaux en fait partie environ
1000 concurrents ont du s’échauffer sur
les bosses de la forêt de champfilly
puis traverser les plaines entourant
manilléamo pour ensuite affronter la
difficulté reine de ce parcours la forêt
de Port-Royal avant de franchir la ligne
au stade Jacques anquantil au total 800
mètres de dénivelé positif avalé en
moins d'une heure pour le vainqueur du
petit circuit de 14 km très satisfait
alors c'est un parcours qui monte et qui
descend effectivement c'est du vrai
trail avec en plus des touches d'humour
de par l'organisation on a des petites
pancartes à plusieurs reprises moins de
30 à l'heure non c'est une très belle
course et on a pris du grand plaisir sur
le tracé version longue de 27 km il aura
fallu un peu plus de deux heures au
vainqueur la course a laissé des traces
pour son premier trail en compétition le
triathlète Jonathan triom repart
satisfait mais avec une entorse de la
cheville j'étais assez surpris c'est
très vallonné c'est bien technique
il y a des parties un peu plus roulantes
mais dans l'ensemble quand on regarde
deux heures deux pour 27 km sur une
gagne ça fait très un peu plus de 13
km/h c'est c'est vraiment lent pour une
course sur route une course route ça se
gagne toujours plus rapidement et là il
y a eu beaucoup de dénivelé moi mon à
mon Garmin j'ai 800 m de dénivelé
positive donc ça commence à faire pas
mal et que démonter des descentes donc
non une très belle course moi j'ai j'ai
pris mon pied tout le monde moi je suis
pas forcément trailer c'était mon
premier trail d'ailleurs en compétition
donc les chemins sont toujours comme je
dis c'est accidenté il y a des cailloux
là avec l'automne il y a les feuilles on
voit rien sur les sentiers donc
effectivement 20e kilomètre moi je suis
parti je suis tombé rien de bien méchant
là je mets de la glace pour trois quatre
jours c'est pas c'est pas c'est petite
blessures finir la course chez les
femmes c'est Fatima sali qui s'est
imposé à la boucler les 14 km en 1h et 8
minutes